[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the popular pat
40 one of the great college football
writers in america senior writer for
sports illustrated back on the program
i came up with a stupid idea yesterday
pat
i thought the pac-12 is bordering on
being irrelevant this season and maybe
in future seasons
why not play games on wednesday night
like own a day
so people are watching your product
commenting on your product it's like
when you play thursday night
you may be a bad football team but
people are seeing the giants on thursday
night play
against you know the buccaneers or the
patriots
why can't i mean playing at 9 00 a.m
local time west coast is that
kind of the game plan well
you know i think they're looking at all
options right now because they are in a
difficult situation but the one thing
dan that i think the pac-12 would have
to get its arms around is saying
we're not as good as the other power
five conferences so we have to go to a
gimmick and that's hard from an ego
standpoint
and a prestige standpoint to say yeah
we're now at the point we got to
schedule like the mac
and like the sun belt and look for
another night to play or another day to
play
you know if you were you're right though
if you look like the friday night games
the big
big ten has started to put one game on
friday night uh the acc has had some
friday night games those get attention
those get a lot of commentary um you
know i think that friday for sure
although it impinges on
on high school sports and you kind of
get that gets a little tricky but i
think friday is a viable option
thursday yes although you're butting up
against the nfl on thursday nights
i think going forward as people try to
recoup
tens of millions of dollars in lost
revenue they're going to be looking at
all options did the selection committee
at least do a drive by with an 18
playoff at any point this year
i don't know if they have uh they've
kept it under the under the lid
uh so to speak they you know i certainly
this would have been a year to try to
break the mold and say what can we do
here to
a have a a more meaningful playoff more
inclusive and more lucrative
uh i don't know whether they ever
actually seriously considered it
to the best of my knowledge no if they
did they they didn't
acknowledge it you know and that's these
people
well the people that run the playoffs
are the people who run college football
the conference commissioners
they are so averse to change uh as we
know it only took 145 years to have a
playoff so i'm not sure they're ready to
uh go to eight yet but there's money
here
these athletic departments need the
money if you said to greg sankey
all right you may not get georgia in
this year but you're going to have
alabama and if we do eight you could get
texas a m in there as well
um you might get a pac-12 team like
oregon byu could get in cincinnati could
get in
to me it's good for college football why
would why would somebody vote against
this
yeah well i mean especially you're right
that i like if you're the pac-12 or the
big 12 and you're figuring to be left
out i would be banging on the table
every day for an expanded playoff
uh you know that here's the thing it was
this year obviously if the calendar
being what it was
in the big ten starting late in the
pac-12 starting late
they're basically out of weeks and you
go to the tv folks and you say okay well
can we just push everything back and
have a bigger playoff they're gonna say
no because then you're getting in the
way of the nfl playoffs
and we care more about the nfl playoffs
and we care about the college playoffs
so
i think that that was basically they ran
out of tv inventory real estate so to
speak
this year now in the future i mean i'm
with you if i if i'm in one of these
conferences that is habitually being
left out
my job every day as commissioner would
be let's expand the playoff
how concerning is it that you have these
uh postponements in the sec
this weekend oh it is you know i mean
they were the league that it was
obviously been the most gung-ho to play
they forged through the first two or
three weeks with no problems and
you know they're going to keep going but
you're losing games and you're losing
chances to reschedule games and
eventually there's probably going to be
an impact on the conference standings
uh and how things play out there but you
lost three games this week
may still lose a fourth we'll see
missouri was making some noises about
having some uh some covet issues that
could possibly jeopardize their game
against georgia
so uh you know it's catching up with
everybody at some point in time
and it's just a question of of how what
the impact is in terms of how the rest
of the season plays out
wisconsin michigan still on right
wisconsin michigan is still on wisconsin
has come out of their uh their
hibernation so to speak and uh
we'll see how many players they have
we'll see what they look like it's been
interesting i did have a stat this week
that
teams that have had two or more weeks
off actually have a winning record when
they come back nine and seven there's
not been a real negative impact to have
two weeks off
how do you assess who's good
that's the best question i don't know i
mean
and that's the the committee i wrote
about this it's going to be a lot of
look
test i think and that's why like i look
at byu i think byu is very good
their competition hadn't been that great
but you say i know a good team when i
see one do they deserve a shot well
maybe maybe not well wisconsin okay
you're going to play six games is that
enough of
a metric uh coastal carolina's
undefeated marshall liberty all those
teams do they deserve a shot i
i don't know how you figure this out
this year i really really don't
and also we have to hand out a heisman
right we have to we do yeah can trevor
lawrence still win the heisman
sure yeah i think he can um you know i
i mean last year chase young was a
finalist despite missing at least one
maybe two games i'm trying to remember
uh in a shortened season it does matter
but he was really good when he was
playing
if they come back and they run the table
the rest of the way and heaps keeps
playing the way he did i expect him to
be a finalist i was going to say be in
new york city but i don't think they're
probably going to have an actual
ceremony in new york city so
uh but yeah trevor lawrence can still
win the heisman sure can you see where
notre dame joins the acc
full-time in football you know i mean i
think that they'll
have some consideration on it after this
year because it's been good for them
yeah
uh you know it really has they saved
their season for one thing
and i mean it's brought a lot of
attention to be in a conference race and
to have that championship game it looks
like they're going to make now
at the end of the year uh i think that
it'll be
under consideration i still think that
everything about notre dame and what
they want to be
will say no don't do it but i wouldn't
be shocked if jack swarbrick the
athletic director is in there saying
this has been pretty good and pretty
easy
yeah it's going to be interesting here
these uh next couple of weeks trying to
get to
a final four and you know as a source
told me about the big ten it's trying to
pass the site test
ohio state just wants to dominate here
and no matter who they're playing just
dominate
wisconsin's not going to get that
opportunity and then you got michigan
now
at 0-3 so that's not a quality win for
an opponent
uh harbaugh's future there with one more
year left on his contract would they cut
ties
a year early i don't think the school
would
you know maybe jim would if he decides
he wants to take another shot at the nfl
i mean
you look at his nfl record it's pretty
darn good i would think
you know people may view him as damaged
goods but he's got a winning record
in the nfl and i mean you know there's
some people employed there that are not
as good as jim harbaugh
so i would think if he wants to go if he
finally just says
it's not going to happen we're not going
to return to glory we're never going to
beat ohio state i'm out of here that
might happen i
don't think michigan would say you're
out
but we'll see things could still get
worse you know i mean that's you lose to
uh wisconsin this week you get pummeled
by ohio state at the end
uh there's there's plenty of losable
games out there i mean that's the state
of the big ten is so bizarre right now i
mean
northwestern purdue is like the big game
of the week
can indiana stay with ohio state
ah we'll see i don't think they quite
i'm not sure their defense can hold up
you know i really like their team
they're fun they throw it they catch it
uh they can score uh i'm just not sure
defensively they can slow down justin
fields and those receivers and the
running backs
it's amazing that we're talking about
indiana in a in a positive way
unprecedented yeah and i i had a source
who said you know it's really an nfl
scout who said look it's really hard to
assess
ohio state quarterbacks because the
talent is so great
and if you're looking at dwayne haskins
it's a one-year
hey what did you see there uh caldwell
uh
what was it uh cardio
and then and now you have uh justin
fields there
like have you seen like hey i know this
guy's gonna be really good here
and it's an ohio state quarterback yeah
no i mean that's a
legitimate question i mean i think
justin fields is very good
i don't just and look i am not a scout
but i don't think he's as good as trevor
lawrence i'm not sure he's as good as
zach wilson
uh at byu he's really good and really
fun
but the that's the thing the offense is
so good the scheme is great
the players around him are great how
much does he really have to do
uh we'll see you know i mean i thought
he was very very good
for the most part like against clemson
you know when you're matched up against
excellent talent excellent coaching in a
big game
but he had some turnovers in that game
still i you know i think justin fields
is certainly going to be a first-round
pick we'll see how high
but there is an element of yeah are we
drafting a guy who everyone around him
makes him look better than he is
good to visit with you pat thanks for
joining us we appreciate your time as
always
my pleasure dan thank you pat forty
senior writer
covering college sports for sports
illustrated